coupez votre client 200 rapports et 50
salles hurle
[Musique]
nous voulons aujourd'hui c'est un
événement un petit peu a pas on va
parler autre chose que la tête qu'on va
parler pop
on va parler de culture pop culture
savait pop culture days qui est juste
ici alors l'idée de la pop culture days
vous explique ce n'est pas un événement
grand public du tout donc vous pouvez
pas venir au moins vous fassiez partie
de la presse
l'idée c'est ça c'est la première
journée presse de la pop culture l'idée
c'est de fédérer un peu tout le monde
autour de la pop culture donc un
événement où il ya beaucoup de monde à
l'intérieur lorsque je vous propose de
faire c'est aller faire un petit tour de
voir qu'il y a de découvrir plein de
choses pour moi c'est un univers qui est
relativement inconnu mais je suis très
curieux je pense que savait le coup il
ya plein de choses hyper intéressante à
voir donc je vous propose de rendre tout
de suite se prendre un petit café un
petit pain au chocolat un truc comme ça
et puis lire
[Musique]
tron et allez ça va on est avec
guillaume bon alors 9h36 c'est très dur
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est des pros de
cultures des haies et pour une fois je
te parle canton de confrères je te parle
en tant qu'inventeur je suis content et
la vita t'invite acteurs clés de
l'invitation
alors aujourd'hui tu vas nous faire un
petit tour du salon gars plein de choses
je suis vraiment novice jeu du coup mes
leçons ça super cool donc non je compte
sur toi pour me faire découvrir et nous
faire découvrir je pense qu'on en a qui
connaîtront mais bon là moi je vais
découvrir concrètement dans les grandes
mines et pop culture days c'est un
rassemblement de diverses marques landes
horizons différents mais tous réunis par
la même passion de la pop culture du jeu
vidéo tu souhaitais la bande dessinée du
manga ouai diverses acteurs du milieu
et tous se rassembler dans un même salon
ouvert uniquement à la presse et aux
professionnels
on commence avec les 404 édition maison
d'édition orientées avec lucie et clélie
comme wild arms and other way donc donc
il par rapport au jeu et c'est un peu
dur
wen moi je suis innocent je découvre je
connais space invaders forcément je
connais pas vraiment des licences non
geeks farc
ouais merci les filles nom sur chaque
attaque maisons d'édition françaises qui
publient du manga du shôjo du light
novel également avec bruno son dirigeant
ou un goulot bonjour en cendrée alors
qu'est ce que tu fais bono dix mois
alors on éditeurs de manga alors on a
une petite particularité c'est qu'on
n'est pas sur paris on est dans le
limousin on va dire que si je caricature
un peu notre ligne éditoriale et en
trois grandes parties la première c'est
la beauté féminine
enfin le manga féminin oui il est
vraiment spécialisés shôjo manga
qu'est ce que c'est bon contre moi-même
km par exemple qui notre best-seller de
shows érotiques adultes auxquels coup le
voilà avec une femme qui a du mal à se
faire accepter dans le monde moderne
très machiste et qui va décider qu'un
jour eh ben il a le droit aussi d'avoir
du plaisir avec un homme de manière
légère voilà on n'a pas un truc un peu
plus les jeunes à notre tabelles
feelgood avec des histoires scène pour
les plus jeunes voilà donc une est
spécialisée dans gros best seller
changement manga si orange donc voilà
qui est on avoue être à 200 mille
exemplaires vendus maintenant en six
tomes donc
beau succès et perfect world l'oci qui
parle d'une femme à dieu et aux demeures
de lycée en toute allure roulant donc ça
c'est une grosse ligne de notre
catalogue
la deuxième mine de notre catalogue si
l'aspect sociétal
on fait beaucoup de livres qui parlent
de sujets de société en plus difficile
l'un vient de sortir mon père alcoolique
et moi qu'il soit vrai d'une femme qui
avait un père alcoolique et si ça parle
de toutes les conséquences que ça sur sa
vie sur son foyer sur pain à l'ail sur
global man ou sur les traces et les
cicatrices et ce à l'aide répétés de
venir écouter un peu dur ou plutôt
rigolo c'est quand c'est pas drôle du
tout c'est pas drôle moi c'est froid si
c'est pas si froid est-ce pas froid
parce que c'est la réalité de sa vie
donc en fait c'est une tradition mais
mondes sont enfin laissant paupières
sans rien donc c'est pas du tout drôle
en fait d'un craspay sénat du catalogue
il est pas très s'ébruite c'est assez
brute de décoffrage par exemple
goodnight iloveyou c'est pas une
histoire vraie mais si l'histoire d'un
jeune étudiant qui a perdu sa mère et
qui va faire un road trip en europe sur
le deuil et cédera la sortie aussi
éclats d'âme qui est assez connu
là je n'ai pas mais qui parle d'un jeune
lycéen gay qui se fait à ôter au début
de l'histoire donc ça parle en même
temps de harcèlement d'homophobie de
découverte d'un milieu qui connaissait
pas d'acceptation de soi donc voilà on a
des titres aussi sur l'écologie
voilà comme ma vie dans les bois où on
parle beaucoup de thématiques voilà deux
sociétés un peu moderne
ok cool et puis notre troisième rosling
éditoriale c'est le label when the fuck
voilà on m'a créé un label what the fuck
d'accord ou pas je pense que le nom du
label est assez clair voilà l'histoire
c'est l'histoire d'un moine qui s'est
réincarné en dessinateur de manga
doit-il aller plus haut mais et quand il
était moine forcément il n'avait pas non
plus voilà tromper son biscuit
il dessine dans schengen est en fait ils
dessinent une héroïne avec des grosses
du concours très grosse poitrine et en
fait il s'avère que comme il est
réincarné x car moine il ya une femme à
la grosse poitrine qui devient son
assistant d un triangle amoureux avec un
ses ex-collègues moines qui s'est
réincarné aussi dans le monde moderne
bâtiment beaucoup des comédies
romantiques dans le chemin de langage on
a fait aussi récemment magical girl is
it qu'il y ait une espèce de parodie de
de tout ce qui m'arrive call girl
laisser leurs monnaies compagnie est en
fait elle n'a rien avoué du sort de
l'humanité tout ce qu'il veut c'est la
laisse tranquille pouvoir fumer quand
elle a besoin de sa dose de nicotine
voilà on a des histoires un peu trash
l'histoire d'un jeune collégien qui
s'ébranlait dans la rivière qui dira
matin donc sur mon c'est la bâloise de
sympathie donc s'amuse bien ça se mange
beaucoup ça un an contre la censure
aussi et puis récemment on a lancé
justement des collectifs de haut niveau
romand de romans japonais donc le label
souche ou qu'un avel trez plus donc des
histoires connecter aux univers turgot
donc là par exemple je patine mes rêves
c'est l'auteur de l'autriche de orange
qui a fait la couverture
et on lance aussi le label young novel
qui seront des histoires 15 plus avec
des sujets un peu plus dur société n'a
lancé sur youtube une chronique jojo
qu'on appelle l'instant chaud pour l on
parle de chevaux manga voilà on va avoir
pour un intervenant
donc on trouve que les gens ils
connaissent pas très bien ce que ça le
soit en manga sa cote est notre maison
d'édition
sion réflexion qui compose la bande
dessinées comics orienté vintage
jeunesse entre les mains de yoann
pourtant parler davantage bonjour ça va
bien toi ça va merci alors qu'est-ce que
tu te voyons explique moi alors maison
d'édition comics comme un commandant a
dit ouais accès bien axé sur les
adaptations de films en comics
principalement des des films des années
90 2000 mais encore les jambes en fait
comme evil dead
est ce qu'elle produit en 1997 il de
carpenter jack burton
aussi quand même assorti ya pas
longtemps on est des fans de dessiner on
est des fans de comics donc on s'est dit
pourquoi pas mais tous ensemble c'est ça
oui bien sûr mais là tu en voilà par
exemple
army of darkness donc il y des aides la
suite de lettres à yves voilà on a
entendu parler en ce moment de la série
age versus evil dead
ouais donc c'est le même univers voilà
c'est la suite directe du film génial on
a quoi on a escape from new york donc
l'urc 1997 quand on a plusieurs volumes
déjà là tu vois donc la suite directe
toujours aussi du film de carpenter
après on a on a line arabe le juge dredd
est que tout le monde connaît qui à la
fois univers bd univers ciné on a deux
types de collections c'est à dire cette
collection un qui était axé signer et le
comics kurdes ou c'est une partie
création une partie adaptations de
licences américain voilà on va te faire
faire un peu de sport
alors j'ai pas n'importe lequel il est
quand même 9h46 tu prends des risques
pour faire du sabre laser d'abord c'est
marie sur manon sa présidente qui est là
pour présenter un projet à l'humanité
que fabre laser adressé un projet qui
date d'il ya quatre ans maintenant déjà
super vite finalement on a créé une
académie de combat au sabre laser en
fait sur une idée un peu folle envie de
de faire ça
et ça a super bien marché contre daegu
pour jean et cetera qui vont s'ouvrir
prendre des cours donc l'idée c'est
d'une part de prendre des cours
à l'année une fois par semaine tu
deviens lundi le soir il ya tous les
jours et ça des cours pour les arbres
toi tu en fais du symbole si c'est le
cas il faut il faut les prendre et à
l'est d'oran la porte on a mis à la cmuc
monsieur grenet move
tu vois que c'est vous alors qu'à des
moves dans ce parc des unités dans le
mouvement
je peux des compétitions internationales
aujourd'hui notamment avec des
américains
l'eia circuit national pour sabre laser
way qui s'est mis en face cette année
géniale
alors comment sa mort en fait ça c'est
un manche en aluminium
oui en aluminium jeu d'higuain qui est
donc là c'est la base du sabre laser et
ça c'est un tube en polycarbonate donc
ultra solide c'est pas en jours et en
fait ouais
on aligne sans tard et là on peut
commencer un stade donc c'est à la toux
la france est avec les peuples
torreilles et le sabre laser rebondit
même seconde alors que tu joue à des
jeux de société et coûtent assez peu
ce que ça t'intéresse de société mais
pas alors bienvenue celle dont 2 pén
baines une maison d'édition de jeux
société français qui propose pas mal de
jeux de société avec des licences phares
tu vas arrêter world xi watchmen tokyo
ghoul je les entraînais one camille qui
va t'en dire plus sur sur ces projets là
avec toi alors tu m'expliquer dont panis
qui bien sûr je t'explique est un peu de
panique donc c'est vrai qu'à première
vue dans la création de jeux cd jeux à
licence votre peau coordonnées de sortie
donc ses attaquants knighton il t'en
aller chercher la licence au japon et on
a pris les meilleurs auteurs de jeux de
société français pour faire un jeu sur
cet univers
donc voilà c'est un jeu à des joueurs
ont joué les personnages de la série est
un des joueurs va jouer un titan bien
sûr le but du titan savez de manger tous
les joueurs pour moi gagner et là il a
sorti aussi une dernière licence la
dernière édition c'est au cube pareil on
allait chercher la licence au japon et
c'est une création française par
l'auteur français et là c'est un jeu de
d'identités cachées ou les personnages
jouant les joueurs vont jouer des
personnages de la série et vont devoir
cacher leur identité et résoudre leurs
objectifs
c'est un jeu très rapide qui jouent en
15 20 minutes
qui est facile à trier et on fait
également des traductions de jeu qui ont
déjà été dites à l'étranger par exemple
on a toute la gamme dc comics ça c'est
des jeux
ça c'est des jeux de société dans
l'univers des super-héros dc avec
superman ça c'est des jeux qui sont
créés aux états unis et ensuite nous ont
fait la traduction et on les rangs pour
la france
edwards pour la france c'est des jeux
qui ont énormément d'extension
on les sort de plus en plus par exemple
là on vient de sortir watchmen c'est une
petite extension qui permet de jouer
dans l'univers de watchmen et là on va
voir ça qui va sortir pour noël c'est
batman versus joker c'est une version
deux joueurs du jeu de cartes d'accord
un jeu batman lodjou le joker il va
falloir mettre ko son adversaire le plus
rapidement possible et là notre
prochaine sortie ce sera pour après noël
ce sera un week-end morty donc le
premier jeu ricaine parti qui sortira en
france ça pareil c'est une traduction
américaine et on c'est un jeu de cartes
qui joue dans l'épisode total recall
on fait également des créations
originales ou d'autres jeux hors licence
par exemple là on vient de sortir lâche
pas la savonnette et qui est un petit
jeu d'ambiance 12 passes en prison où il
ya un seul perdant est le perdant ce
solide et obligeait tout une savane est
plutôt je trouve un peu bizarre comme je
vais peu bizarre mais fun radio et on
fait également des jeux un peu plus on
va dire gamer comme seven renard qui se
passe dans l'univers comme de celui des
sept samouraïs ou deux joueurs vont
s'affronter à rejouer les renards
l'autre va jouer les ninjas et ils vont
devoir essayer de se battre
c'est tout récemment vient de sortir
aussi escape ouest s quel point c'est un
magazine trimestriel qui est disponible
en kiosque et en librairie en boutique
de
spécialisés et le principe c'est chaque
numéro une aventure différente
un univers différents et des énigmes
différence vraiment un magazine avec
plein d'énigmes et à chaque fois des
règles de jeu différents après le jeu
société on va passer sur de la lecture
avec notre maison d'édition est orienté
pas mal pop culture ou trois
illustrations de parler du japon
les studios ghibli de disney jeunesse
entre les mains de marica qui va tendre
dire davantage à ce sujet donc elle a
été présentée le groupe in his animé
landes
bonjour match car une finition c'est une
maison qui édite des livres sur la pop
culture
ok on est surtout spécialisé en
animation et au japon certains penseurs
délivre ainsi d'animation japonaise soir
une animation japonaise
tout ceci grâce à animer landes en fait
un magazine qui est le premier la
première revue sous l'animation
japonaise le manga on fait des livres en
partenariat avec avec un hymne landes
comme les mots courage dommage que vous
avez devant vous un groupe quand cette
série mais le magazine et c'est vraiment
la spécialité de notre maison d'édition
cette finition très travaillé qui
rappelle le livre le marquage à chaud le
vernis sélectif mais sur le sol le fond
on est plus sur un magazine avec des
articles critiques
les anecdotes fouillé sur sur le sujet
en question
voilà c'est vraiment
des oeuvres très riche emilie est ce que
tu peux me présenter l'organisation
alors bon on connaît vos regards pige à
la télé et à guînes encore en tout cas
moins forcément je plateau mais on se
connaît tous et la chance qu'on a c'est
en fait le genre trois tours reprend
exactement ce qu'on vit dans l'émission
yes donc à l'intérieur de la boîte ont
mis toutes les épreuves qui plaisent
dans l'émission et en plus on les a fait
intégralement avec charest cette équipe
on a l'adn de porter quiz dans la boîte
c'est comme si on avait le fast food
mais sans la nourriture le comme toutes
les épreuves de l'émission tout ce qu'on
a aimé le stc doivent évidemment les
deux heures et alors chabal voulait
qu'on mette
ils ont 200 différente de son différent
pour reconnaître quelques chefs les
maillots un abattage
alors je la voulais aussi qu'on fasse un
bloc de commande comme dans les
restaurants donc on a suivi ce qu'ils
souhaitaient et on a mis un bloc comme
ça chacun de mettre ces différents coins
et surtout dans la boîte
334 660 passe de 8700 question est une
grosse partie est faite exclusivement
pour la boîte de jeu qu'on retrouve pas
dans l'émission en fait on a fait un mix
alain chabat et ses équipes voulaient un
mix entre celles qui plaisent est
beaucoup dans l'émission et en même
temps des nouvelles pour qui un verre
d'intérêt aussi afin qu les faits celle
de mission mais aussi les nouveautés
super surprendre de nouveau parce que ce
qui plaît vraiment celle ci toutes ces
questions dans l'émission vous voulez
une question phares redessinés je
m'essaye fédérer pour l'événement
d'aujourd'hui je vous dis quand même
m'être dit mme ce maître yoda ou les
deux
prenons ces phrases à l'envers
[Musique]
maître yoda ah ah oui mais le trio da
oui mais croyez moi
66 cm on est d'où exactement parce qu'on
en sait rien que ça dans le doute à une
villa à marrakech comme ça c'était cette
fois
les gars sont partout la même chose donc
à quelques franchises médiatique la plus
lucrative du monde au 1er janvier 2018
pokémon star wars harry potter diane
femme flic flegmatique blague contre
je fais du monde exactement les données
montrent en effet des jardins a le droit
de recommencer 704 question tout cas
content chez duca merci merci
donc du coup bah là on va t'amener vers
quelque chose qui va davantage te parler
plutôt orienté tech gaming
les godillots cube évidemment dépendre
programmation de avec un aspect puzzle
game et nanomachines jeunesse avec son
créateur mark qui va te dire davantage
sur ce projet et moi
marc est donc je suis le créateur du jeu
est un jeu de programmation qu'on
appelle c'est un jeu de puzzle en fait
on a un petit rebond qu'on a contrôlé un
peu comme le mars rover euros qu'on
envoie sur marseille en fait android
doit aller d'un point a à un point b en
récupérant des ressources et le truc en
fait est que ce rebond va le pourra mais
en prenant des éléments pourraient
mettre dans une grille et quand on
regarde pour voir comment de ce revenu
l'avant et quand ils voient un mur il va
y tourner à droite et il est capable
justement d'aller jusqu'à la fin doit
commander ce robot mettant gracieusement
la grille et dans cette ville a par
exemple on a deux branches et pas venir
je vais tout droit j'ai vu un mur je
tourne la tête en vacances et de la
programmation d'intelligence
artificielle et attend avec donc des
symboles sein des faits aussi bien pour
les programmeurs que les gens qui
veulent apprendre la programmation
jusqu'à bac aime bien ça lui manquait
les logiques notre événement il est
réservé aux journalistes et aux
professionnels et pour les autres
amoureux de pop culture
pour le grand public donne rendez vous à
paris manga on a besoin de grandes
conventions bien connu du milieu laisse
entre les mains de laurent qui compare
la davantage nos jours le mans alors
paris moria dans les grandes lignes
c'est comme son nom l'indiqué paris
manga et ça y fait chaud c'est à dire
l'univers manga et l'univers syfy
américain culture anglo saxonne
intégralité qui représentait c'est à
dire à travers le comité la série télé
le cinéma
le catch l'animation
vraiment chose avec plein d'invités
[ __ ] mille mètres carrés à la fois aux
stands d'animations et d'inviter société
et pas mal représentés soit salon donc
là on va attaquer un
on sort tout
il est jeune société orientée très
orienté pop culture et des licences
phares par les potters
entre directeur du sig les animaux
fantastiques
et c'est que jonathan son créateur d'en
parler jonathan bonjour la mal de
nouveautés chez topigen sur la fin
d'année on a le jeu harry potter une
année à plus tard tous les fans de la
saga vont pouvoir vivre tous les moments
clés de l'histoire
ces frais 20
avant tapé là aussi du coup ça c'est en
fait
maraudeur voir harry potter on ne peut
jouer également un grand nombre de
personnages de harry potter hermione ron
cédric luna les villes et même de drago
et ginnie et même après les méchants
donc là on a bitter petits mots dans le
dernier mode qui se rend sans rappeler
en voldemort et on a tous les méchants
qui vont le rejoindre dans ce dernier
mode de vie là on a aussi une quinzaine
de personnages jouables ce qui est
énorme dans un jeu violent on a chaque
pion pour les personnes les pions sont
là et on évolue vraiment sur la carte du
maraudeur donc c'est poudlard et ses
environs du jeu c'est de remporter la
coupe des quatre maisons
même en réalisant les missions et en
revivant toute la saga d'harry potter
jusqu'ici ultimate battle cars 2 c'est
le meilleur jeu de cartes de super héros
où on va devoir réunir nos teams de
super héros anti matches trois en
deathmatch et allait finalement se
dit tous les autres joueurs
ça c'est la boîte ça c'est le jeu de
cambourg en fait vous êtes un gotham
ok on a
en héros
l'epr est en gros le vilain tour à un
habile ont tenté et un batman et ses
alliés vont devoir discrètement déjouer
leurs plans
donc là on peut jouer dans les méchants
le joker
payne
- ilan halimi
par les queens et en jean et wing
bad girl
double face faute d'accord les quatre
semaines
aucun choix qui vraiment énorme ouais
bon que je vais tous les persos est en
fait si on joue agathe ont fait un deux
contre deux gentils des méchants je
jouais à 6 43 des gens
l'amour on va devoir déjouer les dix
projets maléfiques joker et
ces compagnies
tous les deux les plus importants du
commissariat central fort à damas le
père de gilad aura à la clé or la
tombola berceau hôpital s chemical crime
à l'oeil les égoutte d'ottawa le ceta
malbar wade et l'asile d'arkham pour une
gamme un peu vivre aux enfants on a les
animaux fantastiques jouer dès 4 ans
hyper sympa on est dans la ville on doit
trouver les animaux et les capturer puis
faire des combats sort et autres avec
les auteurs
et justice league et le jeu ici film qui
permet justement de jouer tous ensemble
en fait dans la même équipe contre le
jeu donc on va pouvoir regarder flash
superman batman wonder woman aquaman
cyborg et on va devoir aller jusqu'au
bout pour éclater la tronche d'austérité
juste pour le prouver jolie voix
je présentais pas mal de jeux qui
étaient déjà sortis sur le marché ouais
là on a une petite exclusivité en allant
jouer qui va arriver sur tir startline
en trois semaines d'accord monumental
dans les français d'automne forge est un
jeu de civilisation avec un aspect des
building jour plateau collecte de
ressources
les figurines voilà vraiment jeu assez
conséquent on chasse les claudine va
t'en parler davantage est de présenter
ce projet d'envergure
jean-claude bonjour sarah ya toi alors
explique moi tout nouveau projet ouais
exactement c'est un jeu donc avancer
très prochainement ta jeu de
civilisation
donc tu joues
une des cinq simulation présent dans la
boîte de base d'accords qui sont les
égyptiens les à noah les polémiques qui
font les japonais les grecs et chinois
tu vois avant 6 mois 2 supplémentaires
avec des astres
des atlantes d amato ça c'est cool
chaque joueur joue une civilisation
conciliation en fait c'est un deck de
cartes pâte et une carte 10,28 une carte
en a 15 qui sont communes à tous les
joueurs
on a tous des élèves et en a sept qui
sont spécifiques à des civils
sinon parfaite dont on tour de vieux tu
vas essayer d'aligner enfin dans la
partie
il va essayer d'accumuler des points de
victoire alors en achetant par des
connaissances des merveilles voilà
et d'autres car ils vont te générer des
gains de temps et qui sont tous pros
générer des effets supplémentaires plus
fort que les cartes que tu as dans ton
jeu de base ok donc tu vas les acquérir
tu va compléter ton jeu tu va nettoyer
ton jeu des mauvaise car ils sont moins
bonnes et puis au fur et à mesure et
c'est d'optimiser tous ces biens étaient
points de victoire par ces cartes là et
puis par les ressources qui n'est pas
connecté sur le terrain tu vas le
terrain il a différentes configurations
au départ va tous les joints sont dans
leur ville d'origine dans la capitale ce
que le terrain il est modulaire certes
chaque joueur pourra créer ses propres
terrains on en propose bien sûr mais
chacun créent ces cartes comme il
l'entend d'accord sur chaque tuile
balles et il a donné valeur de défense
elles ont des barbares qui sont su qu'on
peut varier on peut faire varier et en
fait toi tu va amener en fait t'es trop
au fur et à mesure pour conquérir ces
territoires ce qui vont peux te
permettre notamment je faisais des
merveilles que tu va construire pour des
pyramides que ses jetons edge ou autre
et puis tu vas en défens vacants les
barbares tu vas gagner aussi des
ressources soient des ressources du vote
de l'or ou des bâtiments qui va gagner
et qui va améliorer ton jeu dent
l'aspect conquête n'est pas forcément
super important dans le jeu mais en
revanche tout ce qui te permet de
collecter des ressources sur les marchés
sur le terrain est super important parce
que tu vas grâce à ses ressources
acheter de plus en plus du kart et
améliorer tanger d'accord voilà et donc
chaque joueur le jeu son tour l'un après
l'autre
j'ai la mécanique est très simple quand
tu actionne tacite et que tu incline une
colonne et une rangée tu choisis dit
elle et chaque colonne ranger pack e
génération de ressources qui sont
indiqués au suivi siens et sert souvent
de paraître d'acheter les cartes de
faire les mouvements sur le plateau de
jeu quand ta vie ton tour va étudier
fausse les cartes que ça d'activé et
puis tu remets d'écart la hauteur des
prises sachant que généralement vas tu
auras acheter des cartes supplémentaires
qui vont faire que ton
sera meilleur lancement sur kickstarter
le 23 octobre le ventre en club exclusif
intérieure qui sera pas dans le commerce
et après pas du tout pas du tout que
kickstarter kickstarter ok cool c'est
souvent le cas pour les jeux qui sont
extrêmement fructueux à produire comme
celui ci où les figurines sont essam
charaf a provoqué les moules aspect
autrement dit un coup qui fait que si tu
veux que l'opération soit rentable porto
en tant qu'éditeur
ta quasiment pas d'autres ressources
qu'elle quitte cinq ans de plus si un
jeu comme ça arriver dans le commerce
illégal très cher évidemment il ya le
toulon de guînes s'allient donc le
distributeur le marchand petit j'ai
connu c'est très cher
pas les gens sont pas encore jetés un
jour beaucoup trop cher toutefois
tricheurs pas rageux très cher s'il veut
être un outil toi il sera 150 entre 150
et 200 euros
c'est très cher monsieur en mettant sur
kickstarter tu peux en ayant directement
la spec
regardez
le joueur au final tu as tu as des jeux
qui sont accessibles à moins de 100
euros
elle rend accessible
évidemment c'est une contrainte qui sera
fait avec rien cette entité
c'est un public qui est très vigilant
très pointus les joueurs sur
ils suivent ces genres de projets là par
exemple one a commencé à poster les
photos des filles auraient doigts et
tout de suite ça fait le buzz tu vois
les as en action vraiment franchement
vachement joli ça s'est développé en
interne soit son nom le modeleur 3d
il ya chez nous parce que tu vois là
c'est les sorties du zim donc ça sera
des plastiques injectés après sur la
base des boules fait sur ces figurines
la nature
et ça c'est beaucoup de boulot puisque
chaque civilisation ces quatre figurines
différentes voix il ya le chef il ya
l'effort les explorateurs les soldats
mais l'effort est donc
tu as 5 simulation de base puisque notre
civilisation x 4 modèles de vous dire
une fois j'ai beaucoup de choses
agen
j'imagine que tu as la table oui
toujours
je sais qu'on se retrouve toujours au
niveau des buffets là j'ai envie de te
parler d'une petite pépite française
les macarons de mon macaron d'amour qui
propose des macarons geek avec des
licences phares tu vois des au v10 de 30
ans
et des champignons des
j'adore mais j'en passe et des meilleurs
je tiens ce jour des pourparlers sur
projet au fait ça dit toi qui fais les
macarons crs et moi je suis dans la
société après ses deux passes et sierre
qui font les macarons et mont blanc à la
main en fait à professe que vous voulez
voir ses rêves à sur commande
qu'est ce que vous voulez qui peut me
faire guider mon macaron on pourrait
faire guillaume à 40g concours labrit
guillot il ya des cimes bien distinctif
et une aile la culture n'a non plus ça
pourrait la barge et la presse à sa
sortie
je pense qu'il ya un truc inférieur aux
macarons guy canivet d'accord ok cool et
donc là aujourd'hui l'idée l'idée
aujourd'hui comme c'était le pop culture
des c'était de rester un peu dans
l'esprit
ouais avec des
des macarons qui soit un peu si le
dessin animé à peu rétro avec le
laird aujourd'hui mais après midi en
fait on fait on s'adapte à tous les
besoins d'un ptac comme guillaume l'a
dit on a dû mario du tintin duo bdic de
dark vador
on est
et on en passe mais voilà il ya plein de
possibilités je suis l'eau et la pop
culture c'est aussi les arts la
photographie le dessin la peinture
dans le cas présent aux il est parti en
tueuses d'enfants des saluts et saluts
tournage de star wars 2
pas mal de photos ce
repartant sur votre
bush est en dessous d'un vigile être
présenté son projet est de faire
découvrir un peu tous les faux tableaux
qui sont présentés sur le stand alors
moi je suis parti en tunisie en début
d'année en fait pour faire un petit peu
ce pèlerinage donc alors j'évite de
choses j'ai vu des très beaux lieux de
tournage forcément
la fameuse maison lui qui est moi laisse
poser la question si des films j'ai vu
des centaines de fois c'est qu'est ce
qui va se passer lorsque
moi je vais voir ces images je me crée
des images fait la réalité qu'est ce qui
va se passer là que j'ai cette
confrontation un petit peu avec le cadre
la couleur qu'est ce qui va se passer
est que j'arrivais sur les mangues et on
est donc là pour moi on est allé on est
dans l'émerveillement donc un petit
parti pris des toiles l'onirisme le
recadrage et donc je vis très belles
choses sur les décors mais il n'ya pas
aussi que les décors il ya aussi entre
les décors
il ya des images tout aussi belle de
mirage de désert de couchers de soleil
qui ont clairement dit inspiré le jour
des casses et il ya de très très belles
choses à voir en tunisie six ans qu'elle
continue existe c'est le désert tunisien
en fait c'est aux heures nefta c'est un
petit peu du côté la frontière frontière
algérienne
sur un stand de jeux vidéo avec cette
fois ci les petits français de just for
games est un spécialiste de la
distribution de jeux physiques qui ont
deux roses à lens a présenté sur ce
salon
la neogeo me et astérix obélix du succès
de compter dix mètres 6 milliards can en
dire davantage à ce sujet hier salut
bonjour à la roma tout aujourd'hui on
est donc sur le salon du pop culture
days principalement pour compter de
nouveau
j'avais donc premièrement on habite à
xxl 2
en 2018 ok merci on l'éviter et
collector pour que l'état il y aura une
figurines comme celui d'astérix et tee
shirt reprographie enfin petit paquet
jones havas c'est donc la réduction d'un
jeu sorti plus tôt sur ps2 et pc
d'accord
suite
il ouvre la porte en fait à l'excellent
3 sortir en 2019 vous laissera beaucoup
une la suite
déjà star x d'accord l'autre gros
morceau
avait bien plus vite c'est donc la neige
et au mini qui n'ont plus sur nos stands
aussi sur la
doisneau joli ça c'est en a trop dit
prochain reddition de la console de snk
que vous on a connu à 90 donc avec les
manettes typique d'origine la neogeo cd
40 jeu inclut donc les king of fighters
les samurai shodown aller bétail slug il
ya tout ce qu'il faut qu'on s'amusait à
ce projet et l'a pas vraiment l'esprit
borne d'arcade là dessus là c'est
vraiment marqué de repos jouer sur la
d'embarquer le jouer sans la bande à
repérer ce remarquable avec les sticks
et les boutons nacrés fonctionnel tu
fais avant chez 35 heures outils que la
reine catherine foncé sur le secteur de
la pêche plutôt qu'un ordinateur
ouais je marche beaucoup de toi tu joues
camanettes l'a directement sur le safran
ben voilà on peut les déranger
bon j'imagine que tu connais netflix
oui c'est compliqué voilà mais pour
regarder des animés
pas forcément de sur idéal
donc du coup si vous tournez vers
crunchyroll qui diffuse des animés sur
toutes les places port avec un large
catalogue et je te laisse entre leurs
mains pour ensacher
bonjour donc jeu
alors crunchyroll c'est une plateforme s
vod c'est à dire avec un abonnement on a
accès à tout un catalogue la spécialité
c'est l'animation japonaise
on a près de 400 titres 6000 épisode
sous titré en français et la promesse
surtout du service est proposé une série
en seulement une heure après qu'elle a
été diffusée au japon donc l'épisode
passe à la télévision au japon et une
heure après on peut le regarder aussi
toutes les françaises chez soi que cette
fois ça donne un ordinateur il tablait
sur des consoles on diffuse des séries
comme black leur par exemple ça c'est un
grand succès la clover c'est une série
qui est publié au japon qu'il dirait
d'un manga qui est publié dans le weekly
shonen jump c'est le fameux magazine qui
a vu naître
one piece naruto et dans un temps plus
lointain dragoni vol saint seiya donc on
est dans des valeurs shônen dépassement
de soi et ses 1
c'est un carton au japon est ce un
carton si en france la série elle a
commencé depuis plus d'un an et elle
continue elle sera peut-être j'espère le
prochain naruto fairy tail de demain
ouais en ce moment diffuse aussi une
série plus adulte qui s'appelle zong à
mouiller le manga est aussi connue en
france puisqu'il a déjà publié aux
éditions ki oon
et on est sur quelque chose cette
fois-ci
senad public adulte avec une histoire de
chasse au trésor et 2
plusieurs personnes qui vont aller
jusqu'à 100 fois tu es pour essayer de
mettre la main sur une carte qui va pas
amener sur un somme un trésor voilà il
ya énormément de choses nous notre point
fort c'est justement la diversité de
l'offre on peut trouver des comédies
romantiques comme orange ou comme mon
histoire ont trouvé des choses
complètement what the fuck comme top
teams épique une série complètement
délirante
kiki par eudis un peu la culture
japonaise et c'est ce qu'on essaie de
proposer
large spectre de tout ce que peut
proposer l'animation japonaise
aujourd'hui pas combien de produits au
catalogue
on a six ans pendant 400 séries
sous titré français d'accord et on est
actuellement on a dépassé les 6000
épisodes disponibles aucune quand on est
une société américaine on est disponible
en 8 langues dans 160 pays
donc le catalogue un petit peu à l'image
de netflix n'est pas forcément le même
d'un pays à l'autre il ya beaucoup plus
de choix aux états unis parce que
service existe depuis plus de dix ans
mais on est quand même l'offre la plus
importante en termes de diversité de
contenu et
surtout leader à travers le monde sur ce
secteur-là de l'animation japonaise en
streaming
c'est quoi le coup la bombe enlèvements
il est à 4 euros 99 par mois résiliable
à tout laurent c'est même encore moins
cher si on sabote
et à la différence d'un service comme
netflix ou amazon on a aussi la gratuité
sur
nombre d'épisodes alors avec des
restrictions si vous regardez en gratuit
vous aurez de la publicité avant et
pendant l'épisode et s'ils ont un
abonnement permet d'avoir accès
immédiatement
dernier épisode et et sans publicité
avec un meilleur confort à la visionnage
dernier stand avec un quart natis est un
ouvrage en réalité augmentée avec un
aspect transmédia je savais que son
auteur mark de présenter ce projet là et
découvrir sociaux semblent cool alors
expliqué parce que lecture aux réalités
augmentées on expliqué c'est très simple
en fait
il incarne à 10 c'est un univers
transmédia un univers où pouvoir
découvrir de différentes façons en
ouvrant des portes comme aux chouettes
aujourd'hui la première porte
c'est un libre qui propose une nouvelle
expérience de lecture augmentée
concrètement un livre imprimé et glémaud
qui raconte une histoire est en cours de
route si on le souhaite on mieux accéder
à des médias additionnel très simplement
en scannant des qr codes au fils des
pages
d'accord mais voilà on peut venir
normalement
comme bâle est normal mais si en plus on
se cache on a accès à des récits audio
on va trouver la voix française d'eva
longoria maison musée qui raconte des
choses à voir cancer de montréal crim
anoci et d'autres voient aussi d'acteurs
de doublage qu'on est allé chercher dans
le premier puits dans le deuxième volume
qui sort bientôt cea-leti audio sont mis
en musique avec des vrais musicale sur
l'une d'elles on a acheté sur ma
choristes qui chantent en latérite rouge
ils s'envoient bien
on va trouver aussi des illustrations
fait par étienne l'euro qui est un
auteur de bande dessinée pourra trouver
des musiques composées spécialement pour
accompagner la lecture de certaines
scènes et même deux objets magiques 2
artefacts qu'on pourra en réalité
virtuelle avec l'application incar
bâtisse 16 médias qui vont permettre
d'aller au delà du texte
d'où l'idée de lecture
quand même temps c'est très immersif
pour entrer dans ce nouvel univers sur
inscription fantastique fantasy public
réalisé des dépenses et la portée
une autre façon d'aborder le livre c'est
quoi la volonté alors le point de départ
c'était de créer un univers transmédia
avec différentes réalisations et après
ça pose l'éternelle question des moyens
du temps et ce sera donc un moment donné
en 2010 je veux aussi des bons je vais
commencer par un livre avec une
problématique qui était comment je vais
mettre les médias deux ans ce que je
voulais pas mettre le lien internet
parce qu'il faut poser le bouquin à
sortir l'ordi ses petits enfants inxs
est une chose que tu pourrais faire ça
pourrait aussi tout à fait là j'ai
choisi les qr codes parce que ça me
semblait très simple et tout le monde
peut y accéder aisément qu'aujourd'hui
on voit qu à côte au cheikh fall flashy
on réfléchit pas et pas une
démonstration technologique
mais on réfléchit effectivement à
d'autres expériences médias dans le
deuxième volume qui sort à la fin du
mois on va aller plus loin dans les
illustrations augmenté
dans des scènes jouées décèle lui avec
de nouveaux acteurs aussi qu'ils vont
faire leur apparition
et comme la voix française de samuel l
jackson thierry desmots
francis taulan aussi qui nous a fait le
bonheur de nouveau enregistré un
personnage
quelques bonnes surprises à fait
sympathique et cool alors on a fait
faire un petit tour de notre événement
de yann culture days
quand j notre basse et surtout suite ça
que imaginé ce projet
ce projet il ya six mois il ya un an et
je te laisse
je laisse mon amie sarah batteux parler
de ce projet alors ça raconte moi tout
ça alors effectivement il ya un an à peu
près
je me suis dit qu'il nous fallait un
événement moi je suis je fais des
relations presse dans la pop culture
depuis nombreuses années et je vois que
les journalistes ils sont surchargés on
ne peut pas les avoir au téléphone ont
pas l'air d'avoir par mail on dépense
des sommes faramineuses pour leur
envoyer des livres qu'ils lisent pas ou
des produits qui ne l'utilisent pas et
du coup cet événement s'était faite pour
ça c'était pour croquer une rencontre
d'accord
intéresser les journalistes leur faire
gagner du temps ci parce qu'il voit tout
le monde de court sur une même journée
et puis faire gagner du temps et de
l'argent à toulouse expo d'accord on
s'est dit qu'il fallait fédérer tout
moment dans un même lieu mais c'est ce
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui avec cette
première vie donc là on est aux
prévisions au marais d'accord première
édition qui dit première édition du
deuxième édition wii 3ème édition
donc ça veut dire que l'idée c'est que
ça revienne régulièrement exact ok cool
a essayé d'en faire au moins deux fois
par an donc pour être se caler sur les
plannings des éditeurs aussi parce qu'il
ya des moments forts dans l'année noël
les vacances aussi oui énormément de
ventes donc céder on va se caler sur les
moments clés des éditeurs lève pour leur
proposer du coup un outil de promotion
ok bon vous êtes satisfait ça va être
content on est très 7 on est content il
ya du monde on attend encore plus de
monde dans la journée bon bravo mr
sympathique de l'événement il ya plein
de jolies choses les macarons très beau
le café est bon les gens sont sympas bon
bah on se revoit leur prochain premier
vrai façon très bien de trop sur un
prochain et vote de la semaine prochaine
ces gens qui voient des google
ok cool merci
[Musique]